in the lead up to its release hallo
games and Sony have been releasing
videos showing you the kinds of
shenanigans you can get up to in no
man's sky when the game arrives next
month the four guides to the galaxy were
centered around exploration fighting
trading and survival here's everything
we now know the first video showed the
player jet-setting off into space
and exploring a small but varied
selection of the 18 quintillion
procedurally generated planets once
you've had your fill of staring into
starry space you'll be able to land on
any planet you choose observe and
catalog the local flora and fauna
discover new life and find out who
uncovered it before year aside from
being home to different creatures and
plants the planets also appear to have
their own variations in atmosphere
temperature and potential hazards if you
want to change up your adventuring with
a little renegade action combat is
totally a thing you can get stuck in to
blast your foes to smithereens with your
ship and join massive existing battles
that are being waged above the surface
of nearby planets the guns attached to
your ship aren't the only ones you'll be
able to go to town with though instead
of cataloging the local wildlife you can
also choose to shoot at it until it
falls down
although doing so appears to draw the
ire of Sentinel drones which come in
both hovering and gargantuan form so
you'll need to save some bullets for
them to when you're done killing
everything in sight
you can make a little time for trading
in their third video hello games showed
off the ability to scan planets for
points of interest like beacons and
minerals and gather natural resources
like flora and iron it looks like you'll
be able to mine a whole lot of
geological formations and plant life for
useful bits and pieces both on the
ground and out in space you can then
make your way into a star port to both
buy and sell cool stuff you've collected
out in the galaxy you also seem to be
able to gather blueprints and product
recipes and discover new technology and
build new come home
and moths for your ship exosuit and
multi-tool it looks like you can alter
your ship's weapons health scan
capabilities and hyperdrive
functionality and also enhance the
protection stamina health and utilities
stats associated with your XO suit last
up came the video on survival you'll
want to be wary of hostile planet
environments like extreme heat or cold
toxicity and high radiation levels which
can all hurt you the best way of doing
so is you guessed it going back inside
or you can upgrade your EXO suit with
the appropriate protections if the
planets trying to kill you doesn't seem
like enough of a challenge it appears
some of the wildlife want to have a shot
at you as well it looks like you'll need
to be careful of both your EXO suits
capabilities and oxygen levels while
trying not to piss off too many things
that want to squash you or shoot you in
the face as you go about being the
galaxy's best Explorer trader or [ __ ]
that's everything we gathered from the
latest no man's sky videos let me know
if you caught anything else and what
you're keen to get up to in the game